CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS WILL
COME TO ORDER- IN RESPONSE TO
COBIT NINETEEN- EMERGENCY AND A
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES. WE MUST LEARN
HOW TO GATHER INCIDENT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS
WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC INTO THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE ARE POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. FOUR
ONE EIGHT FIVE. AND THE AXE
CODE IS SEVEN ONE. FOUR FOUR.
ZERO NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS HOW THE TELL. TO
WORK PLEASE REFER TO THE SAN.
AND ARE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC YOU'LL BE BY A
MODERATE TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME WILL BE ON
MUTED AND YOU WERE NOT READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. FOR
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU THANK
YOU. FOR YOUR PATIENCE. ALL
MAINTAIN. DECORUM DURING THIS
HEARING HAS DISCUSSED. AND ANY
INTO. WHO IS TO THROW. MAY
REMOVE FROM THE ROOM MEETING
SERVICE HAVE THEIR- MUTE. WELL
THERE WERE EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE
JUST THE PER. AND CAN HERE IS
AS IN AS CLOSE AS- A MATTER AT
AS CUSTOM. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PROTESTS WHO ARE
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
WE HAD A BILLS ON OUR AGENDA
TODAY FILE ITEM ONE SB NINETY
BY SENATOR STERN. HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM THE HEARING AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR. WE ALSO
HAVE TWO ITEMS ON CONSENT.
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATIONS ON
THE BILL'S LET'S ESTABLISH A-
QUORUM. AS CHIEF CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THANK YOU
SANDERS REMINDER PLEASE TURN ON
YOUR MICROPHONE AND SPEAK INTO
THE MIKE. GLAZER HERE GLAZER
HERE NIELSEN. NIELSEN HERE
HERTZBERG. LEYVA NEWMAN YOUR
NEWMAN HERE. VERY GOOD A QUORUM
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED NOW THAT
WE HAVE A QUORUM OF TWO BILLS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR SB
SEVEN TWENTY NINE FILE ITEM
SEVEN AND SB SEVEN NINETY FOUR
FILE ITEM EIGHT IS THERE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOVE A MOVE BY SENATOR NIELSEN.
THE CONSOLE WOULD UP PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
ADOPT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH INCLUDES ISSUE SEVENTY
NINE AND SB SEVEN NINE FOUR
GLAZER. HI GLAZER AYE NIELSEN
NIELSEN AYE HERTZBERG. LEYVA HI
LEYVA AYE NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN AYE
WE WILL PUT THAT ITEM ON- CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT-
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS OF REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS
INCLUDING PROTOCOLS THE
TIME LMITS ON TESTIMONY I EACH
SIDE WILL BE PREVENTED AN EQUAL
AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE TERM
GERMAN BY THE CHAIR FOR TODAY'S
HEARING EACH SIDE IS PERMITTED
WONDER TO LEAD WITNESSES WHO
MAY SPEAK FOR A COMBINED TIME
OF THREE MINUTES DIVIDED AS
THEY PREFER. ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS DIDN'T THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED TO TOTAL TWENTY
MINUTES OF TESTIMONY INCLUDING
SPEAKING TIME OF ANY LEAD
WITNESS. ALL RIGHT LET'S BEGIN
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO A
SENATOR ALAN SB SEVEN FIVE TWO
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS IN A. WE WERE
KNOWLEDGE IDENTITY DAY TODAY I
KNOW WE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT ON
THE FLOOR. A LITTLE LATER TODAY
BUT I JUST WANT TO FIRST THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF- AND THE
CHAIR FOR WORKING WITH ME AND
WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS BILLS SB
SEVEN FIFTY TWO. THE TERM
IMPROVES ELECTION TRANSPARENCY
BY UPDATING AND CLARIFYING
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS ON
POLITICAL ADVERTISING. IN THE
PETITION PROCESS. OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL DECADES- THERE HAVE
BEEN NUMEROUS POLITICAL
TRANSFORM PARENTS THE REFORMS.
ORIGINATING STARTING OUT WITH
THE NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR
POLITICAL REFORM ACT. IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN MANY YOU MAY RECALL
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
DISCLOSE ACT WHICH BUILT UPON
THE FOUNDATIONS OF THE PR IS
CAMPAIGN DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS BY SETTING A FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR THRESHOLD. TO
BE LISTED AS THE CAMPAIGN'S TOP
FUNDER AND MODERNIZE THE
CONTENT FORMATTED DISCLOSURE
STATEMENTS ON POLITICAL
ADVERTISING. AND THEN WE DID
THE PETITION DISCLOSE ACT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TO BRING THE
SAME TRANSPARENCY MEASURES TO
THE PETITION PROCESS. BY
REQUIRING PETITION CAMPAIGNS TO
DISCLOSE THEIR TOP THREE
FUNDERS THAT WHEN. OUR FELLOW
RESIDENTS WERE. INTERESTING TO
GO GET SOME. YES SOME LETTUCE
AT THE MARKET AND SOMEONE COMES
UP TO THEM AND FOR US A-
PETITION IN FRONT OF THEM AND
SAYS THAT YOU KNOW SIGN HERE
THIS WILL SAVE WESTERN
CIVILIZATION AS WE KNOW IT. ARE
THEY YOU KNOW THEY AT LEAST
HAVE SOME INFORMATION AS TO WHO
IS FINDING. THIS EFFORT THE
FUNNY THING OF COURSE IS THAT
WE KNEW THAT A LOT OF THE
SIGNATURE COLLECTORS THEMSELVES
AFTER TIME DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHO
IS PAYING FOR THE CAMPAIGN THEY
JUST KNEW THEY ARE GETTING PAID
FIVE BUCKS A SIGNATURE. AND
WE'RE ANXIOUS TO GET THE
SIGNATURE. NOW SO WE GOT THE
BUSINESS BECAUSE ACT ON A FEW
YEARS AGO WHICH MADE IT SO THAT
THAT- THAT THE GOOD FOLKS WERE
WERE SUPPOSED TO BE DISCLOSING
THE DONORS TO A CAMPAIGN TO THE
INDIVIDUAL VOTER WHO WOULD BE
SIGNING THESE PETITIONS BUT THE
LAST FEW ELECTIONS HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED TACTICS THAT OF
COURSE HAVE BEEN USED TO AVOID
TRANSPARENCY I USED TO SERVICE
CHAIR THIS COMMITTEE I REALIZE
IT'S A LOT OF OUR WORK IN SOME
RESPECTS INVOLVES. COMING OUT
WITH NEW TRANSPARENCY RULES AND
THEN CONSTANTLY FIXING THEM AS
AS PEOPLE WHO WANT TO KEEP
VOTERS IN THE DARK FIND
LOOPHOLES AND THAT'S THE THAT'S
ARE A LOT OF LIFE HERE MEMBERS.
AND SO. THE CURRENT FORMATTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR POLITICAL TV
ADS. UNDER THE DISCLOSURE I.
CAN MAKE TAXED I'M CLEAR TO
VIEWERS AND ONLINE ONLINE
GRAPHIC ADS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
DISPLAY ANY TOP CONTRIBUTORS.
SOME PETITION SIGNATURE
GATHERERS HAVE NOT BEEN SHOWING
SIGNERS THE OFFICIAL TOP FUNDER
SEAT AS REQUIRED BY LAW. SO
POLITICAL ACTION COMMITTEES OF
UTILIZED YOU LOOPHOLE TO HIDE
THEIR TOP FUNDERS AND LOCAL
LEGISLATIVE RACES WITH
CONTRIBUTIONS JUST UNDER FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR IT WE SEE
NUMBER FORTY NINE NINE NINE
NINE. SO AS TO AVOID DISCLOSURE
UNDER THE CURRENT DISCLOSE ACT
THRESHOLD SO WE'VE GOT ALL THIS
DISCLOSE ACT DISCLOSURE
LEGISLATION WE FOUND A LOT OF
LOOPHOLES WERE NOW TRYING TO
TIGHTEN THEM UP. AND SO THIS
BILL. DOES A COUPLE THINGSIT
TURNED IT INTO CLARIFIES
FORMATTING REQUIREMENTS ON
POLITICAL ADVERTISEMENTS AND
PETITIONS THE PEOPLE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO. ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
ARE. WITH THAT WE CAN
REASONABLY SEE THE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHO THE TOP DONORS ARE
THESE CAMPAIGNS OR PETITIONS
COLLECTION DRIVES THE BILL ALSO
TIGHTENS THE CONTRIBUTION
LOOPHOLE BY LOWERING THE
THRESHOLD. TO BE CONSIDERED A
TOP CONTRIBUTOR TO TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN LOCAL LEGISLATIVE
AND BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
RACES. AND I HAVE THIS MORNING
AT TRENT LANG WHOSE PRESENT
EXACTLY DIRECTOR THE CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK U. S. SENATOR ALLEN SO-
AS YOU INDICATE TRENT LANG- IS
THE- LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS A-
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE-
OPEN UP. MR LANG'S LINE TO MAKE
IT HEARS TESTIMONY. WELL I
DON'T OPEN PROCEED. ALL RIGHT
AT- THANK YOU AT EVERY GOOD
MORNING CARE GLAZER AND MEMBERS
ARE TRAVELING AT PRESENT IN THE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR SB
SEVEN FIFTY TWO WE ARE GRATEFUL
TO SENATOR ALLEN FOR OFFERING
IT IN FOR HIS CONTINUED LONG
TIME LEADERSHIP IN CAMPAIGN
DISCLOSURE AND- AND FOR FAIR
ELECTIONS IN GENERAL WE DUBBED
THIS BILL THE DISCLOSURE
CLARITY ACT- BECAUSE IT
CLARIFIES SOME OF THE-
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS TO MAKE
SO MUCH EASIER TO- TO SEE FOR
VOTERS BUT THEY COULD ALSO BE
CALLED THE STOP ABUSES OF THE
DISCLOSE ACT ACT- THAT'S NOT
QUITE AS CATCHY SO WE DIDN'T GO
WITHOUT. A BUT THAT'S REALLY
WHAT IT IS- SO GENERAL
DESCRIBED OVERWHELMING
BIPARTISAN MAJORITIES IN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
CALIFORNIA'S CLOSE ACT AND THE
PETITION DISCLOSE ACT TO SHOW
VOTERS THIS CRUCIAL INFORMATION
OF WHO FUNDS POLITICAL ADS AND
MISSION OF CAMPAIGNS- BUT WE'VE
SEEN SOME OF THE PIECES THAT HE
DESCRIBED. IT FOR ABUSES IN
PARTICULAR THAT THIS BILL.
ADDRESSES- ONE OF THE- KEY IS
THE- ON TELEVISION ADS WE'VE
SEEN OUR- THE NAMES I HAVE
SUPER A LONGER COMMITTEE NAMES
THAT TAKE UP THREE OR FOUR
LINES OF TEXT SO YOU CAN'T GET
DOWN TO SEE THE TOP THREE
FUNDERS IN THAT LITTLE BLOCK
AND THAT LITTLE BLACK BOX THAT
THE DISCLOSE ACT REQUIRED ON TV
ADS IN THE FIVE SECONDS THAT'S
ALLOTTED SO SB SEVEN FIFTY TWO
SAYS THERE HAS TO BE SOME
SPACE. BETWEEN THE COMMITTEE
NAME WHICH IS OFTENTIMES
MISLEADING AND THE TOP FUNDERS
ON THE BOTTOM AND MAKE THE TOP
FUNDERS BE IN YELLOW VERSUS
WHITE FOR THE COMMITTEE NAME SO
THAT STANDS OUT AND POPS SO. A
VERY SIMPLE STRAIGHTFORWARD-
REALLY- MAKES IT EASIER FOR
VOTERS TO SEE THE TOP. BOB. I
JUST HEARD SOMETHING THERE BUT-
OKAY- JUST I'LL GO ON- FOR
ONLINE ADS- IT'S CLEAR FIVE
THAT THE WE'VE SEEN- FUNDERS
ARE NOT ARE COMPLETELY BE USING
THE REQUIREMENT BILL THAT HE
CLEARLY READABLE TO THE AVERAGE
VIEWER I'M VERY HARD TO READ IN
SOME OF THESE ADS SO PUTTING UP
A SOLID BLACK BOX THE
DISCLOSURE ON ONLINE ADS THAT
CAN BE BRED. MR ALLEN SAID ON
LARGE ONLINE THAT YOU HAVE TO
SCHOOLS AT LEAST ONE TOP WONDER
LIKE EVERY OTHER KIND OF THAT
YOU ALREADY MENTIONED THE
PROBLEM OF ALL THE FORTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLAR CONTRIBUTES TO
A LOT OF LOCAL AND LEGISLATIVE-
INDEPENDENT EXPENDITURES FOR
AGAINST CANDIDATES TO LOWERING
THE THRESHOLD TO TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS ADDRESSES THAT. AND
THEN ON A PETITION DISCLOSURES
UNTIL SIGNATURE GATHERS HAVE
NOT BEEN SHOWING VOTERS THE
REQUIRED TOP FUNDER SHEET IN
MANY CASES- BOB WHEN THEY USE
THAT OPTION AND DON'T WITH THE
TOP ORDERS ON THE PETITION SB
SEVEN FIFTY TWO WILL MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE TO THAT THERE'S
A LINE RIGHT ABOVE THE
SIGNATURE BOX FOR EVERY
SIGNATURE. DO NOT SIGN UNLESS
YOU SEE AN OFFICIAL PARTNERSHIP
AND THE MONTH IS STILL VALID SO
THAT SHOULD MAKE CLEAR TO EVERY
SINGLE VOTER WHEN THEY SIGNED
THAT THE NEED TO SEE THAT
OFFICIAL POP UNDER SHEET BEFORE
THEY SIGNED AND THEREFORE THAT
THEY HAVE THE INFORMATION THAT
THE LEGISLATURE UP VERY WISELY-
REQUIRED THEM TO SHOW SO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT-THIS A WEEK AGO A SIMPLE
STRAIGHTFORWARD CLEAN UP BILL
TO- BIG SURE THE WILL THE
LETTER. IN THE BOAT TO SEE THE
TOP OF IS TO. AND WE- OCCURRED
YOUR BOAT THANK YOU YOU THANK
YOU MISTER. ABSOLUTES THAT THAT
AND THAT WAS THE LEAD TEST AND
THEN THE THREE MEN OF BEEN A-
SO LET'S SEE IF THERE ANY OTHER-
WHO CAN GIVE NOW THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL- IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE WISHING
TO TESTIFY C. NINE. WILL MOVE
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE IS OR ANYONE
AT RISK ONE TWELVE. NOT SEEN
ANYONE THERE WILL MOVE TO THE-
ANYONE WHO'S CALLING VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE PROP ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WISHES TO.
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
FIVE TO- TO DO SO NOW. THANK
YOU. STATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB
SEVEN FIVE TWO MAY USE YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD AND PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME PLEASE.
NEVER MIND THOSE- FOLKS WHO ARE
GOING TO TESTIFY THAT- THE
TESTIMONY HAS ALREADY BEEN
GIVEN SO JUST TO INDICATE YOUR
NAME AND- ASSOCIATION OF ANY
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL.
GO AHEAD MODERATOR. THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE SEVERAL LINES IN Q.
AND WE JUST A MOMENT PLEASE.
FOR THE FIRST. MY NUMBER
SIXTEEN ONE SIX LINE IS OPEN.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE ALIGNMENT.
TWENTY ONE TO ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S MICHELLE SLAUGHTER AND
THE DIRECTOR OF MùT MONEY OUT
VOTERS IN AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FIFTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE
EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHT. HI THIS IS
SHEILA **** CALLING ON THE
COURT CONTRA COSTA MOVES ON AND
MONEY OUT PEOPLE IN PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL MOST OF THE
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE WANT TO
KNOW MORE ABOUT MONEY AND POWER
GRAN METALIK DISTRICT AMEN YOUR
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION
PLEASE THANKS SO MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE TWENTY TWO
TWO TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS MARK POWERS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THE%
RADIO AND TV STATIONS SERVING
YOUR DISTRICTS WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE TWENTY FOUR
TWO FOUR. YES MY NAME IS
CAROLINE STAPLETON FUN THE
PUBLIC POLICY DIRECTOR FOR
HOLLYWOOD NOW WE ARE VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE SENATOR
ALAN STILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TAX CALLER PLEASE. MISTER
JOURNAL FOR THE LINES IN QUEUE
FOR SUPPORT AT THIS TIME I WILL
GIVE IT ONE LAST SHOT TO ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE LINES PLEASE
THAT. INDICATE BY DIALING ONE
AND THEN ZERO LET'S GIVE IT ONE
LAST CHANCE OPERATOR FOR
ANYBODY FURTHER. THANK YOU AS
SATED BY THE CHAIR THAT'S
WONDERFUL ABOUT ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THANK YOU
KNOW I THINK YOU AT THIS TME
TERRIFIC OKAY SO WE'VE HEARD
FROM SUPPORTERS NOW WILL GO TO
OPPONENTS THERE IS NO LEAD
OPPONENT- SO INDICATED- LET'S
GO TO. ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. NOT SEEN
ANY WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE
NOT SEEN ANY WILL GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINES OPERATOR.
YOU PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WHO WAS
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION SB SEVEN
FIVE TWO TO. SO INDICATE. THANK
YOU TO STATE YOUR POSITION OF
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. YEAH
MESROP POSITION OF SB SEVEN
FIVE TO ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. YOU HAVE ONE LINE
IN Q. LINE TWENTY THREE TO
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING SCHERING COMMITTEE
INSTANCE. CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS. I WANT TO MAKE SURE
I'M IN THE RIGHT PLACE I WAS
JUST LISTENING TO A BAND ALLEN
BILL IS THAT CORRECT SB SEVEN
FIVE TWO. IS THAT WHAT I AM
THAT'S CORRECT. GO AHEAD PLEASE.
I'M IN THE RIGHT PLACE YOU DID
NOT HAVE A LEAD WETNESS IN
OPPOSITION IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THIS BILL IS NOT GETTING EQUAL
REPRESENTATION ON BOTH SIDES
WOULD YOU MIND EXPLAINING TO
ME- THE PROCESS AROUND. I'M
SORT OF A NOT AS- WELL I'VE
SEEN HERE IN THE CAPITAL MANY
TIMES AND- IN TESTIMONY MANY
TIMES YES MY NAME IS ANDREA HAD
STRUM BUT SEE THIS IS NOT MY
WHEEL HOUSE. AND IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT BOTH SIDES SHOULD GET
REPRESENTATION AND SO WE'RE
WE'RE AT THAT MOMENT IN THE
HEARING WHERE IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
PLEASE GO AHEAD THE TIME IS
TICKING. I WOULD LIKE TO BE
YOUR LEAD WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
WE HAD ONE IN THE FOREST WHY
WOULD YOU NOT GIVE ME THREE
MINUTES THE CALIFORNIA I AM AND
NOW WE'RE FORTY FIVE SECONDS TO
DO IT SO PLEASE. GO AHEAD.
VERIFICATION DOCKS ME WILL YOU
TO DIE. THE RECALL PEOPLE WITH.
SIX THREE. AND YOU WANT TO TALK.
TO RECALL. WERE SEVEN FIVE TWO.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN. WHY IN THE
WORLD WOULD WE NEED TO SAY ANY
MORE THAN THE TWO MILLION PLUS.
SIGNATURES HAVE ALREADY COME IN.
BECAUSE YOU WON'T OPEN THE
BUILDING YOU'RE DOING THIS
STUFF IN THE DARK AND NOW YOU
DON'T HAVE A LEGAL WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION AND IT SEEMS ABSURD
TO ME. GO FOLLOW CALLING ON AT
NINE AM ON A MONDAY MORNING IS
THE ONLY PERSON IN THE QUEUE.
AGAINST THIS I'M AGAINST
EVERYTHING THIS COMMITTEE IS
DEALING WHAT THE PEOPLE INTO
THE BUILDING AND STOP WITH THE
SHENANIGANS BECAUSE TWO POINT
ONE MILLION SIGNATURES. THE
MESSAGE YOU NEED. I FOR TIME
BECAUSE I COULD KEEP GOING FOR
AWHILE. ANYTHING ELSE YOU WANT
TO SHARE. BELIEVE ME A LOT I
WANT TO SHARE BUT I'M GONNA
KEEP THIS CALL G. RATED. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
NEXT THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN AFTER OUR
ANY OTHER LINES IN OPPOSITION.
TO SEVEN FIVE TWO THIS PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN Q.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR OKAY WILL BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SENATORS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS CENTER NEWMAN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
SENATOR ALLEN FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK. AND NOT JUST IN THIS BILL
BUT OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS. SO THERE ARE THERE ARE
TWO CHANNELS OF EFFECTIVELY FOR
COMMUNICATION THAT ARE. AB
SEVEN DRESSED IN THIS BILL WHAT
ONE IS ELECTRONIC THE OTHERS IS
PETITIONS- I'M INTERESTED IN
PETITIONS TO SHOW. APPRECIATE
THE IMPROVEMENTS JUST MAKES BUT
WHAT WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
ENFORCEMENT- IN MY EXPERIENCE
MY OBSERVATIONS. VERY HARD TO
BRING EFFECTIVE ENFORCEMENT- TO
ABUSES AT THE PETITION LEVEL
PARTICULARLY. IN THAT SCENARIO
THAT YOU DISCUSSED YOU KNOW
THAT THE CLASSICS OF IN FRONT
OF YOUR GROCERY STORE
INTERACTION. YEAH SO HERE I AM
ACTUALLY ENGAGING IN ROBUST
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW TO BEST
ENSURE THAT THE THAT THE PEOPLE
ARE ACTUALLY SHOWING THIS
SHEET. WHICH THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO SHOW AND- WE'VE BEEN GOING
BACK AND FORTH ABOUT GIVING. AT
SO OBSERVE ONE OF THE IDEAS WAS
TO HAVE SOME SORT CHECK BOX.
WHERE YOU HAVE TO CHECK DID TO
AFFIRM THAT YOU HAD ACTUALLY
BEEN SHOWN. THE SHEET. AND IF
THAT BOX WASN'T SIGNED AND THEN
BECAUSE I THAT BOX WASN'T
PICKED IN INITIAL THAN THAN
THAT WOULD- THAT WOULD RENDER
THE SIGNATURE INVALID ANOTHER
POSSIBILITY WAS TO. REQUIRE
EVERYBODY TO JUST PRINT THE TOP
DONORS RIGHT THERE ON. THE
FRONT OF THE PETITION FORM. AND
TODAY IT'S RIGHT THERE FOR
EVERYONE TO SEE AND THEN THE
OTHER POSSIBILITY WAS TO HAVE A
LINE IN THERE SAYING. HERE DO
NOT SIGN UNLESS YOU SEE. THE
TOP DONOR FORM SUGGESTED TO PUT
MORE INFORMATION. AND MORE.
DISTRIBUTIVE FLOORING IN FRONT
OF THE OF THE OF THIS OF THE
SIGNATORIES- UNDER THE RADAR
SCREEN SO AS TO REALLY GOING TO
PUSH THEM TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY HAVE THIS RIGHT THIS
RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE A LOOK.
AT THESE TOP DONORS. SO THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING
ON- WITH THE COMMITTEE IS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
INSURE THAT THE- THIS ISSUE IS
ADDRESSED. THE ENFORCEMENT OF
COURSE IS A REAL THING I MEAN I
MEAN OBVIOUSLY ANYONE WHO
VIOLATES THE CURRENT LAW AND
SUBJECT TO. THE PENALTIES.
UNDER THE FTP OF PPC BUT AS WE
KNOW THIS IS A- KIND OF A- VERY
HARD TO POLICE WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THEM MANY MANY
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE OFTENTIMES
VOLUNTEERS WHO ARE ENGAGING IN
THIS PRACTICE. SO THAT'S ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY WE WANTED TO
COME FOR LEGISLATION THAT
WASN'T JUST RELYING ON
ENFORCEMENT BUT THAT ACTUALLY.
INCREASE THE CHANCES OF NOT
ABOUT NOT NEEDING ENFORCEMENT
RATES IT'S OBSERVE MORE
LANGUAGE RIGHT THERE ON THE
DOCUMENTS THAT THE VOTERS
SIGNING THAT. THAT THAT. WOULD
WILL HOPEFULLY FOCUS VOTERS
ATTENTION ON THE IDEA THAT
THERE IS THIS. SHE AVAILABLE
THERE IS THIS INFORMATION
AVAILABLE THAT THEY THEY CAN
THEY SHOULD. TAKE A LOOK AT IT
WHEN THEY WHEN OUT BEFORE
BEFORE MAKING A DECISION AS TO
WHETHER THE SIGN. I APPRECIATE
THAT I JUST THINK. IT'S YOU
KNOW IT REMAINS. A REAL
CHALLENGE IN CALIFORNIA- TO
COMPEL EFFECTIVELY COMPEL
SHOULD YOU GUYS PARTICULAR
PROFESSIONALS PARTICULARS ARE
INCENTIVIZED BY THE PERSECUTION
BOUNTY. ALL RIGHT TO BE HONEST
AND UPSTANDING AND YOU KNOW
THERE'S VIRTUALLY I MEAN I
STAND THE PANEL IS ALREADY IN
PLACE AND APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS HERE- BUT IT'S IT IS
SELDOM TO THE POINT OF BEING TO
MINIMIZE THAT A. ANY ACTIONS
ACTUALLY TAKEN AGAINST-
UNETHICAL SIX AGO. BUT I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING AND WHAT YOU
DO IN HEARING YOUR THOUGHTS
REMOVED FOR THANK YOU MR. L.
COMMENTS TO CENTER NIELSEN.
KERN WROTE LET ME BE CLEAR HOW
DOES THE- SENATORE THEN. WILL
THERE BE A LIST OF QUESTIONS ON
THE PETITION THAT THEY WILL
HAVE TO SAY YES I WAS FULLY
INFORMED- AND YES I KNOW AND
THIS IS MY NAME AND HOW MUCH
BURDEN ARE WE PUTTING ON THAT
INDIVIDUAL SO IN DISCUSSION
WITH THE COMMITTEE ULTIMATELY
WHAT WE LANDED SO WHERE IT IS
NOW AND I CERTAINLY WELCOME THE
ENGAGEMENT OF THIS COMMITTEE
ALL THE MEMBERS BUT WHERE IT
WHERE WE LANDED IS THAT WE
WOULD WE WERE SO INITIALLY
THERE WAS THAT THAT CHECK BOX.
A REQUIREMENT THAT THE CHAIR
HAD SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THAT-
AND SO WE ALSO WE REPLACED IT
WITH A DISCLAIMER IN EVERY
SIGNATURE BOX THAT SAYS VERY
CLEARLY IN CAPS DO NOT SIGN AND
LESS. YOU HAVE SEEN OFFICIAL
TOP FUNDER SEAT AND IT'S MONTH
THE STILL ABOUT. SO THAT IT'S
UP TO DATE SO THAT'S WHERE WE
THAT'S WHERE THE BILL IS RIGHT
NOW SO THERE'S ONLY ONE SINGLE
PLACE THAT THEY HAVE GOT TO
AFFIRM THAT THEY HAVE. THEY'VE
BEEN RIGHT IT'S RIGHT THERE IN
THE SIGNATURE BOX HOPEFULLY
THEY'LL READ IT THEY'LL SEE IF
THEY'LL SAY HEY I HAVE THIS
RIGHT TO SEE THE SHEEP BUT- YOU
KNOW. WHAT WE WANT TO TELL ME A
LITTLE MORE OF US THEN PUT IN A
GOOD POSITION TO THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS WHERE WE'VE WAITED BUT
CERTAINLY HAPPY TO. AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD TO WORK WITH. ALL
OF YOUR OFFICES TO TRY TO. WELL
THE KEY IS NOT BEING PUT IN ON
REASONABLE BURDEN ON THIS. ONE
SIGN. THAT SAID FRANK THAT'S MY
CONCERN RIGHT I THINK THAT WAS
WHAT I THINK THAT WAS WHAT
MOTIVATED THE CHAIRS- CONCERNS
AS WELL AND- YOU KNOW WE GOT TO
A PLACE WHERE. IT'S CLEAR.
BRIGHT LINE. I'VE YOU KNOW. IT
IT WILL BE HARD TO ANYONE WHO'S
ACTUALLY READING WHAT THEY'RE
SIGNING THE LEASE THAT THAT
LITTLE PORTION OF THE AREA
WHERE THEY'RE SIGNING- IT WOULD
BE. IF IT'S PRETTY CLEAR TO
THEM THAT THEY THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT AND THEY OUGHT TO LOOK AT
THAT A THE FINDER SEE- BEFORE.
A LOT OF THE A LOT OF THE
SIGNATURE. WERE DURING THAT
PART OF THE REQUIREMENT. HAVE
TO BE IN ANY. PARTICULAR TYPE
SIZE THAT PARTICULAR LANGUAGE-
I BELIEVE IT'S IN THE SAME.
TYPE SIZES THE OTHER. LANGUAGE
IN THE- IN THAT BOX. THE ONLY
THING THAT WE'RE REQUIRING IS
THAT THEY DO NOT SIGN IN LAST
B. IN CAPS. VERY GOOD CENTER
NIELSEN. MATT HI BEFORE THE
QUESTION SURE- SENATOR. A QUICK
PHOTO SO HOW DO WE PAY DO WE
ACCOUNT FOR. POSSIBLE IN THE
TICKING OF THE BOX ARE YOU IF
YOU'RE NOT MANAGING A
SIGNATURE. HOW COULD YOU
POSSIBLY ACCOUNT PARTICULARS
THAT SIGNER WILL NEVER SEE THAT
PETITION GOOD HOW HOW CAN WE BE
SURE THAT WE KNOW THAT A BOX
WHEN TECH WAS PICKED BY THE
SOONER THAT IS THE SEVEN DAY
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT THAT
YOU CHECK A BOX ARE YOU INITIAL
BOX IT SAYS RIGHT IN THE
SIGNATURE BOX. DO NOT SIGN
UNLESS YOU HAVE BEEN INFORMED
OF THE FUNDERS OKAY SO WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY SIGNED THAT PETITION
YOUR IN A BOX WHERE IT THERE'S
TWO DIFFERENT SEARCH THERE'S
NOT ADDITIONAL STEPS NOW. THAT
WASN'T CLEAR THAT THE
INITIATIVE- CIRCULATORS AND
CENTER ALLEN CAN CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG HAVE TWO OPTIONS NOW
UNDER HIS LEGISLATION ONE IS
THEY CAN PUT ON THE SIGNATURE
SHEET ITSELF THE TOP FUNDERS
AND MAKE SURE IT'S UPDATED
EVERY MONTH THAT'S A NEW
REQUIREMENT. EXCUSE ME THAT'S A
REQUIREMENT THAT'S IN A LOT
TODAY- BUT THAT THERE THERE WAS
AN ALTERNATIVE THE ALTERNATIVE
WAS TO HAVE IT ATTACHED- IF THE
SIGNATURE PROPONENTS WANT TO
STILL HAVE AN ATTACHED SHEET
THEN THEY HAVE TO ACTUALLY PUT
IN THE SIGNATURE BOX THAT YOU
SIGN THAT YOU HAVE BEEN MADE
AWARE THAT YOU USE IT YOU
SHOULD BE MADE AWARE WHAT'S THE
EXACT LANGUAGE SENATOR ALAN. DO
NOT SIGN UNLESS YOU'VE SEEN THE
OFFICIAL TOP HONORS UNITS MONTH
THE STILL VALID SO THAT IS A
NEW PROVISIONS UNDER THIS
LEGISLATION IF THE IF THE
PROPONENTS DECIDE TO HAVE THAT
ATTACHED SHEET- WHICH IS WHERE
THE CONCERN HAS BEEN RAISED
THAT UP THAT THAT WASN'T BEING
SHOWN. AND ENDED CENTER NEWMAN
AYE AYE I JUST I SHOULD HAVE
BEEN MORE CLEAR AS I DESCRIBED
AS OUR REGIONAL BILL HOW. THE
TICK BOX. I SOME OF OUR ARE
STILL VERY THE TO BOX- I WE
WOULD MAKE ANY CHANGES WITHOUT
THE FULL CONSULTATION THE
COMMITTEE ARE BUT I THINK WE'VE
GOTTEN TO A PLACE WHERE WHERE
WE'RE COMFORTABLE NOW WITH WHAT
THE COMMITTEES ACCESS TO DO
WHICH WAS TO DROP THE TICK BOX
REQUIREMENT AND JUST PUT IN
THIS ONE REQUIREMENT WHERE IT
SAYS DO NOT SIGN UNLESS YOU
SEEN THE- THE SHE- AND THEN
THAT WILL BE PLACED RIGHT INTO
THE BOX. WHERE PEOPLE ARE
SIGNING BE. THE PETITION-
APPRECIATE SEGMENTED TO DISCERN
USES POINT YOU KNOW IT DID WITH
RESPECT TO THE QUESTION OF WHAT
IS BURDENS OF WHAT IS WHAT IS
TOO BURDENSOME. I THINK IT'S
NECESSARY TO INTRODUCE SOME-
FRICTION OF THIS PROCESS TO
ENSURE THAT VOTERS ARE.
PROPERLY ENGAGED IMPROPERLY
AWARE DENNY QUITE OFTEN I THINK
TODAY IT'S TOO EASY- TO SIGN
PARTICULARLY YOU KNOW UNDER
THE- KIND OF REPRESENTATIONS
AND URGING OF PRECIOUS SIX YOU
GOT IT LIKE HEY DON'T COST YOU
ANYTHING PUSH ON. THEIR- AND SO
BUT YOU KNOW I LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING HOW THIS PROGRESSES VERY
GOOD. ALL RIGHT ANYTHING
FURTHER AT CENTER ALLEN THAT
FOR THE ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE ONE
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
THOUGHTFUL LEADERSHIP AT THE
SPACE. I THINK THAT YOUR BILL
THAT'S BEFORE US TODAY REALLY
HAS THE RIGHT. BALANCE OF A
MUCH MORE AGGRESSIVE DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS- AND I THINK THAT
WILL GO A LONG WAYS TO-
ENSURING THAT. THAT WE NEED TO
SIGN UP. THAT YOU'RE MUCH MORE
AWARE OF WHO'S PROVIDING THE
FUNDING YEAH I THANK YOU FOR
THAT THAT COULD WORK THAT
YOU'RE ADVANCING THE PLOT.
BUDGET CLOSE YEAH I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND I AND I
NEEDED TO GO TO YOUR POINT
CENTER NEWMAN AYE AYE. DURING
THE LAST ELECTION CYCLE
ACTUALLY I WENT TO THE MARKET
AND I GOT CHI CHI STEP THROUGH
THE MARKET VICE SIGNATURE
COLLECTOR WHO WAS MAD AT ME.
BECAUSE I WASN'T DOING HIM A
FAVOR OF YOU KNOW EARNING IN
THE EXTRA SIX DOLLARS BY
SIGNING AN INITIATIVE THAT I
KNEW ABOUT AND I DIDN'T
SUPPORT. AND HE REALLY WAS
OFFENDED THAT I WASN'T YOU KNOW
TAKEN MY TO COUPLE A MINUTE OUT
OF MY TIME TO GIVE A SIGNATURE.
WHICH WOULD WHICH WOULD HAVE
GOTTEN PAID. AND I NEVER FORGET
THAT. ON THERE FOR HOW IT'S HE
WAS. EVEN I DIDN'T I DIDN'T SAY
ANYTHING. A ANY SUBSTANCE I
JUST I WASN'T INTERESTED. IN SO
I SO I THINK YOU TO THE CHAIR I
CERTAINLY FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH
WHERE WE ARE NOW- I THINK THIS
WILL AT LEAST PUT AN ADDITIONAL.
REMINDER IF THE- YOU KNOW IT
DISCLOSURE TO THE TO THE VOTER
THAT THEY ABSOLUTELY CAN AND
SHOULD AND MUST. LOOK TO SEE
WHO'S BEHIND THESE INITIATIVES
BEFORE SIGNING. SO I THINK IT'S
I THINK ULTIMATELY GETS TO A TO
OUR CORE GOAL. AS A STATE WILL
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE COMMITTEE
AND THE MEMBERS- IF THERE ARE
ANY ADDITIONAL CHANGES I DON'T
ANTICIPATE THE NEED FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL CHANGES. I AM
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
ABOUT IS THERE A MOTION FOR THE
COMMITTEE. WILL BY SENATOR
NEWMAN. THE CONSOLE ONE CALL
THE ROLL. PRESS B. SEVEN FIVE
TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GLAZER AYE GLAZER HI NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG. LEYVA
RIVER BY NEWMAN AYE NEWMAN HI-
SO THAT'S A THAT'S A THREE TO
ONE WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS CENTER ALLEN IF
YOU HAVE THAT CATION TO. HAVE
ANY FURTHER DAMAGE IN THIS BILL
GOING FORWARD I WOULD BE
HONORED TO BE LISTED AS A CO
AUTHOR THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. ALL RIGHT SO WE'RE
GONNA ON NOW TO. ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB FOUR FIFTY NINE BY
SENATOR ALAN WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN. PLEASE
PROCEED. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
LET ME START BY SAID ACCEPTING
RETENTION LIMITS ON PAGE SEVEN
OF THE ANALYSIS. SO MEMBERS
THIS BILL GIVES THE PUBLIC THE
PRESS AND LAWMAKERS MORE TIMELY
AND USEFUL INFORMATION ABOUT
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT
ARE SPENT. TO INFLUENCE THE
FLEET THE FATE OF LEGISLATION
IN CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU HERE
IN OUR STATE. ARE LOBBYING
FIRMS. AND THE INTEREST GROUPS
THAT HIRE THEM. ARE REQUIRED TO
FILE QUARTERLY REPORTS ON THEIR
LOBBYING ACTIVITY ONE MONTH
AFTER THE CLOSE OF EACH QUARTER
SO THE THIRD QUARTER THE Q.
THREE REPORT COVERS THE MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN A
QUARTER OF THE YEAR WHICH IS
JULY THROUGH SEPTEMBER WHICH OF
COURSE INCLUDES THE- HE-
INFAMOUS. FINAL WEEK OF SESSION.
THE DURING THIS QUARTER
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ARE SPENT
TO INFLUENCE LEGISLATION BUT
THE DISCLOSURE FOR QUARTER
THREE DOESN'T OCCUR UNTIL AFTER
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY
DECIDED WHICH BILLS ARE PASSED
TO PASTOR TO FEET END. AFTER
THE GOVERNOR HAS DECIDED WHICH
BILLS TO SIGN OR VETO. SO HERE
WE ARE YOU KNOW WE'VE GONE
THROUGH THE LAST BILL WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TRYING TO ENSURE
THAT THAT PEOPLE HAVE WE SOME
SEMBLANCE OF INFORMATION OF
WHAT MONEY IS BEHIND. THESE
CAMPAIGNS WHEN THEY ARE ASKED
TO SIGN A PETITION FOR EXAMPLE
OUTSIDE THE MARKET. I'M HERE WE
OFTENTIMES HAVE NO IDEAS
LEGISLATORS WERE VOTING ON A
DIFFICULT CONTROVERSIAL BILLS
AT THE END OF SESSION UNDER A
VERY TIGHT TIME FRAME WE
OFTENTIMES HAVE NO CLUE. WHAT
KIND OF MONEY HOW MUCH MONEY
AND CREWS BEING HIRED BY THE
SPECIAL INTEREST GROUPS THAT
ARE SEEKING TO INFLUENCE. OUR
VOTE. SO ARE SOLD TWO MILLION
RIGHT NOW. A REPEAT OF THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS BASICALLY.
GOOD FOR HISTORIANS NOT GOOD
FOR WORK FOR US NOT GOOD FOR
THE PUBLIC NOT GOOD FOR THE
PRESS NOT GOOD FOR ANYBODY. WHO
WANTS TO ENSURE. THAT THERE'S A
LOT MORE WISE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS BECAUSE THE END OF THE
DAY. ARE THE DISCLOSURE THAT
THE CURRENT SYSTEM PROVIDES.
PROVIDES INFORMATION LONG AFTER
THE FATE OF LEGISLATION IS
DECIDED AS I SAY NOT ONLY AFTER
THE LEGISLATURE ITSELF IS HAS
DECIDED. ON ITS VOTES BUT
AFTER. THE GOVERNOR'S. MADE HIS
DECISIONS AS TO WHETHER TO SIGN
OR VETO. SO NEARLY HALF THE
STATES IN THE COUNTRY PROVIDE.
OUR FOR REQUIRED MONTHLY
REPORTING OR IN SOME INSTANCES
EVEN MORE FREQUENT REPORTING
CALIFORNIA HAS TO DO MORE TO
ENSURE THE POLICY MAKERS. THE
PRESS THE PUBLIC HAVE MORE TIME
WHEN YOU SAW INFORMATION ABOUT
THE LOBBYING. THAT IMPACT
PUBLIC POLICY SO THIS BILL
TAKES A THREE PRONGED APPROACH
TO INCREASE LOBBYING
TRANSPARENCY. AND TO MODERNIZE
THE REPORTING PROCESS FIRST OF
ALL THE EXPEDITES THE ADVOCACY
ACTIVITY. REPORTING FROM
QUARTERLY TO MONTHLY FOR THE
HIGHEST SPENDING LOBBYING FIRMS
AND INTEREST GROUPS. REQUIRES
THEM TO INDICATE THE SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE POSITIONS THAT THEY
TOOK. DURING THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS RATHER THAN SIMPLY
LISTING THE BILL NUMBERS. THE
BILL ALSO REQUIRES REPORTS OF
SPENDING ON ISSUE ADS WITHIN
SEVENTY TWO HOURS THIS AND
REQUIRES INTEREST GROUPS TO PUT
THEIR NAMES. ON THEIR ADS FOLKS
MAY REMEMBER- THERE'S MORE AND
MORE THESE ADS POPPING UP ON
FACEBOOK THEY'RE VERY TARGETED.
AND OFTENTIMES THEY HAVE FAR
FAR LESS DISCLOSURE THAN THE
OTHER KINDS OF- ADVOCACY
ACTIVITIES THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
THE LAST BILL. SO I HEAR WOULD
BE TO TEST MY SUPPORT TODAY ARE
JONATHAN MATTISE STEIN WHOSE
EXECUTIVE COM CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE AND ALSO DOOR ROSE IS
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS. DIRECT THANK
YOU SENATOR ALAN SO WE WANT TO
INVITE MR STEIN THIS ROSE TO-
PROVIDE LEAD TESTIMONY THERE'S
THREE MINUTES IN COMBINATION
SO. I DON'T KNOW WHO'S
ORGANIZED TO GO FIRST BUT
PLEASE UP PROCEED. OPERATOR
VEHICLE YOU'RE A MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. MY NAME IS
JONATHAN NOT TO SIGN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE WE ARE PLEASED TO SPONSOR
US BEFORE FIVE NINE. OUT WHICH
I CENTER ALLEN MENTIONED AS
THREE MAJOR THINGS AND WON MY-
FIRST IT CREATES MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND LOG AROUND
LOBBYING IN SACRAMENTO
PARTICULARLY FOR THE BIGGEST
PLAYERS AND AT PEAK PERIODS.
CALIFORNIA'S QUARTERLY LOBBYING
REPORTING SCHEDULE STAND
UNFLATTERING CONTRAST WITH A
NUMBER OF OTHER STATE.
REQUIREMENT THROUGH THE BOBBING
REPORTING A MUCH GREATER
TRANSPARENCY CRITICAL PERIODS
AND ALLEGE THAT ACCOUNT. SB
FOUR FIVE NINE AT CENTER ALLEN
SUGGESTED. FOR FORM
CALIFORNIA'S BOBBY DISCLOSURE
RULES TO BE MORE. IN LINE WITH
THOSE OTHER STATES. THANK SB
FIVE NINE WOULD REQUIRE. BOB
GROUP. WHO HAVE TO WITH EACH
LOBBY ON. ALL DISCLOSED THE
POSITION. ON EACH OF THOSE
THAT. WE BELIEVE IS A
COMMONSENSE CHANGE THAT WOULD
MAKE A LOT OF THE SOLDIERS MORE
USEFUL. THIRD SB FOUR FIVE NINE
WOULD INCREASE DISCLOSURE
TRANSPARENCY AND REPORTING ON
ISSUES THAT. THE US GOVERNMENT
ANONYMOUS ATTACKS ON
LEGISLATORS LIKE YOURSELF. FOR
THE AND FINALLY THE BILL WOULD
MAKE SMALL CHANGES TO MAKE
LOBBYING REPORTING EASIER AND
MORE MODERNIZED. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE
IS PROUD TO HAVE THE SUPPORT
GOOD GOVERNMENT COMMUNITY FOR
THESE COMMON SENSE REFORMS THAT
WILL GIVE THE PUBLIC A CRASS
AND U. S. LAWMAKERS MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT- SEEKING TO
ENFORCE LAWS MADE IN OUR NAME.
CALIFORNIANS I WAS A COMPLETELY
THANK YOU JESUS FOR CHAIR AND
HERE'S WE RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR
I. ON SB FIVE. THANK YOU MR
STEIN- THIS ROSE PLEASE PROCEED.
THE MORNING CARE GLACIER
MORNING MEMBERS DOOR RATHER
STEADY DIRECTOR LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS IN CALIFORNIA. SO FAR
FROM NINE FUNCTIONS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT LEGAL TO BE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIANS KNOW NEW SPENDING
LARGE AMOUNTS OF MONEY TO
INFLUENCE LEGISLATION THAT'S
BEING MADE AND THEN IT. AND
THAT WE HAVE REALLY MEANINGFUL
WAYS TO CHECK THE PUBLIC
PROMISES SPECIALLY THE PROMISES
OF LARGE CORPORATIONS. ACTUALLY
MATCH THEIR LOBBYING ACTIVITIES
TO THE ISSUE THAT'S COME UP A
LOT RECENTLY ESPECIALLY IN THE-
CONTEXT OF CLIMATE CHANGE- AT
THE SAME TIME YOU KNOW
LEGISLATORS TO LEARN INSIGHT
INTO SPECIAL INTERESTS AND
MAYBE LOBBYING BEHIND THE
SCENES TO PROMOTER KILLED YOUR
BILL. DEPENDING ON THE
DISCLOSURES ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
IT DOESN'T HELP TO FIND OUT WHO
SPENDING MILLIONS TO INFLUENCE
LEGISLATION AFTER IT' ALREADY
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR. RIGHT
THAT MISSION WE ALL THAT I HAVE
WHILE THE SAUSAGE IS BEING
MADE. SO WE BELIEVE THAT
OPENNESS. YOU KNOW WHEN SIMILAR
LEGISLATION WAS INTRODUCED IN
COLORADO SEVERAL YEARS BACK
LOBBYIST THEN NOTED THAT IF
IT'S REALLY CLEAR OR EVERYONE
STANDS ON THE BUILDINGS ARE
MUCH MORE NATURAL EXCHANGE OF
IDEAS. AND AS YOU ALL KNOW WE
THAN I DO THANK OF GIVEN TAKE
THE LEAD TO THE REAL IMPROVE
LEAD. OUTCOMES FINALLY REPORTER
POINTED AFTER LOOKING AT
LOBBYING RECORDS COMMON CAUSE
ESTIMATED THAT THE MORE.
REPORTING WERE. ONLY TO TWENTY
FIRST OF INTEREST GROUPS. THAT
PORTENT BECAUSE THAT IS.
VISIBLE INTO YOUR OF THE- MOST
POWER INTERESTS. OFFICE CAR
GARNER OTHERS RIGHT LIKE LIKE
SHE NON. THAT SIMPLY HAVE THE
COULD. TO HANDLE THAT DISH
LIMITS DIMINISH REQUIREMENTS.
ISRAEL CAN. UNDER OUR- LEADERS
IN ADDRESS. GOOD GOVERNMENT
CHANNEL AND WE URGE OUR- BEFORE.
THANK YOU MISS ROSE THING YOU
MISTER STEIN. WE'RE NOT GONNA
TO WITNESS- WHO CAN GIVE THEIR
NAME WITH. AND INDICATE OF ON
THIS FIRST FOR GONNA BE AND I
ROOM TO ONE NINE ONE IS YOUR
ANYONE HERE. NOT SEEN IN WILL
GO TO ROOM ONE. NOT SEEN ANY
THEIR WE'RE GONNA GO TO WORK
TELL. LINE OP WOULD YOU UP ANY
OF WHICH TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
S. B.
FIVE NINE. THE SECOND
PRODUCT IF THERE'S ANYONE LIKE
THE STATE TO SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO OVER THE LINE
TWENTY SEVEN TWO SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI TRENT LANG-
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A FIFTY
FOUR FIFTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THEY'RE KNOWN FOR THEIR LINES
INTO AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT NOW
WE'RE TO GO TO OPPOSITION-
THIRTY ONE HERE I HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION- NOTED ANYONE HERE
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
NOT SEEN ANY WILL GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE. NOT SING ABLE GO TO
OUR TELECONFERENCE LINES
OPERATOR WOULD YOU A QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO WISHTO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP FOUR FIVE
NINE. INSTRUCTIONS ONCE AGAIN A
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO YOU WANT TO SHARE YOUR
POSITION OF OPPOSITION TO SB
FOUR FIFTY NINE. ONE DOWN. ZERO
THERE ARE NO LINES IN CUBA WILL
REPEAT THE STATE OPPOSITION
PRESS BEFORE FOR TWO NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU OPERATOR.
WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CENTER
NIELSEN. MR MORE THAN JUST A
GREAT CONCERN THAT IS SEPARATE
BIG TIME HERE OF LATE. IS HE
CAN AFFECT INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
THE TEMERITY OR THE INTEGRITY
TO SIGN PETITIONS TO BE SINGLED
OUT AND SUBJECTED TO MADE
VULNERABLE TO. UNDER PRESSURE
AND I THINK THIS IS A STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION AND I'M GOING TO
VOTE NO BECAUSE OF THAT IT'S A
BIGGER DEAL THAN JUST THIS BILL
BY FAR BUT THIS NOW BEING
THREATENED AND OF IT BEING
PROPOSED FORMALLY AWARE
INDIVIDUALS CAN BE IDENTIFIED
AND THEN- SUBJECTED TO IN FACT
ONE OF THE BILLS EVEN THEN
ALLOWS THEM TO TURN THE LIST OF
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO SIGNED
OVER TO. POLITICAL COMPANIES
KNEW FOR PAY. PUT OUT. THAT.
THE I CAN'T I CAN'T GO FOR THAT
TO STEP TOO FAR FOR ME AND EVEN
THOUGH THIS MAY BE A SMALL STEP
I CAN'T GO LONGER. THANK YOU
SENATOR NIELSEN SENTIMENT
MISTER CHAIR IT WAS JUST A
MOMENT. SIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE
THAT I THINK I KNOW PERCENT AND
ONCE YOU GO SORRY MR PLEASE
RESPOND DIRECTLY TO THE PROJECT
WITH WITH WITH WITH WITH WITH
RESPECT ON MISTER VICE CHAIR
AYE. I THINK YOU MAY BE TALKING
ABOUT. CENTER NEWMAN'S. SIX
SIXTY. EIGHT TALKING ABOUT THAT
GENERAL IDEA NOT SPECIFICALLY
HIS BILL BUT THAT GENERAL IDEA
THAT I SEE SURFACING MORE OFTEN
NOW. OKAY BUT THIS BILL HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH SIGNATURE
COLLECTIONS THERE'S THIS BILL
IS PAST DUE WOULD LOBBYING
DISCLOSURE. BUT IT DOES ALLOW
FOR NAMING AND SHAMING. OUR
ANALYSIS AND WELL AND I'M GONNA
GIVE YOU HAVE MORE OPPORTUNITY
BUT LET'S GET LET'S PUT LET'S
COMPLETE DECK THAT MEMBERS
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FIRST AND
WE'LL GIVE YOU A CHANCE SENATOR
NEWMAN JUST AS BILL HARRISON
RANKING THANK YOU MR SO I'VE
JUST TO KNOW THAT THE BILL
JERRY BEING REFERRED TO IN MANY
CASES SB SIX SIX THREE HAS BEEN
WITHDRAWN. OUT OF DEFERENCE TO
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
AROSE AROUND PRIVACY RIGHTS SO
THAT THE BILL'S A TO YOUR BILL
RIGHT NOW SO NOT NOT RELEVANT
TO HEAR BUT- DID SUPPORT I
THINK TO NOTE THAT WE RESPECT
THE CONCERNS AROUND PRIVACY BUT
TO BE RUN INDIVIDUALS MY
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR IN THIS
CASE IS ABOUT THE PROVISION FOR
INDIVIDUALS. WHO PURCHASE
ADVERTISING- AND IT'S I GUESS
IT'S MOSTLY MECHANICAL HOW WITH
THOSE YOU KNOW PRESUMABLY SOME
OF THOSE PEOPLE MIGHT NOT HAVE
HAD PRIOR EXPERIENCE BEFORE
DECIDING TO TAKE OUT ADS ON
SOCIAL MEDIA ABOUT A PARTICULAR
ISSUE HOW WOULD THEY LEARN
ABOUT THESE REQUIREMENTS AND IF
THEY WERE- EIGHT ZERO OUT OF
COMPLIANCE HOW WOULD THAT THEN
BE. COMMUNICATED AND ENFORCED
TO THEM. IF TO B. C. CURRENT
ENFORCEMENT- YOU KNOW THE WE
HAVE TO BE SEIZE THE ALWAYS. I
THINK THE ALL TREAT WHO ARE.
FIRST TIMERS- WITH A LITTLE BIT
MORE. A LITTLE BIT MORE SPACE.
AND BUT YOU CAN YOU COULD MAKE
THAT SAME ARGUMENT ABOUT ANY.
ANY ANY ENTRANCE INTO THE
POLITICAL SYSTEM RIGHT WHEN WE
KNOW WHEN YOU WHEN  FIRST RAN
FOR OFFICE- WE HAD TO LEARN THE
RULES TO DIG THROUGH THE AGENT
RUN AND- I THINK THAT'S TRUE
BUT IT BUT IT'S ALSO TRUE THAT
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE NOT RUN WITH
THERE'S A VERY SPECIFIC PROCESS
TO GET ON THE BALLOT. THERE'S
LOTS OF DIFFERENT WAYS TO TAKE
OUT ADS SO YOU KNOW IF THEY'RE
GONNA NOT. RIGHT THERE SHOULD
BE SOME EDUCATION COMPONENT-
AND MAYBE THROUGH THOSE
ENTITIES THAT ACCEPT THE ADS
FOR POLITICAL MESSAGING. AB AND
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE GOING TO
LOOK AT THE AGGREGATE TOTAL YOU
KNOW IF IT'S THOUSAND FACEBOOK
THOUSAND YOUTUBE JOB SEARCHES
AND SO IT'S JUST SOMETHING TO
THINK ABOUT- YOU KNOW SO THAT.
WE WILL WIND UP IN A SITUATION
WHERE SOMEBODY WHO OTHERWISE
THINK THAT THEY'RE ACTING
HONORABLY UNSERVED LEGALLY.
FINDS ITSELF ON THE WRONG SIDE
OF THIS. IT'S GREAT POINTS AND
I'M I CERTAIN. BUT TO ME TAKE A
LITTLE DEEP DIVE IN AND SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO TO ENSURE THAT.
THIS IS NOT ENFORCED IN A WAY
THAT'S UNFAIR OR PUNITIVE OR OR
AND. I THINK IT LOOK EVERYTHING
YOU JUST EXPRESS IS NOT IN THIS
ACCORD WITH MY GOALS HERE
BRIGITTE THANK THANK YOU
MISTER- SENATOR- ALLEN- IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT
REQUIRES A SPENDING EXCEEDING
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN A
CALENDAR QUARTER OF TWO REQUIRE
REPORT IS THAT RIGHT YES. OKAY
IT'S NOT SO DIFFERENT THAN A
MAJOR DONOR THRESHOLD THAT WE
HAVE UNDER CURRENT LAW WHICH IS
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THE
HAVE THAT OBLIGATION AS A MAJOR
DONOR- I WANTED TO SAY I THINK
THE DISCLOSURES ONE OF THE BEST
THINGS WE CAN DO TO TRY TO.
IMPROVE OUR OUR- POLITICAL
PROCESS AND I APPLAUD YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND TRYING TO
TAKE THESE- THESE ISSUES UP
PARTICULARLY AS IT RELATES TO
THE THIRD QUARTER- DISCLOSURE I
THINK THAT'S A IN PARTICULAR
IMPROVEMENT THAT I APPLIED AND-
I THINK THAT- AS YOU HAVE SAID
IN AT TESTIMONY ON A PREVIOUS
BILL. AT THE THESE THAT THESE
THINGS ARE WORKS IN PROGRESS
AND AS WE EXAMINE HOW THEY ARE
WORKING WE SEE WHERE THEY ARE
WORKING WELL AND WHERE THEY ARE
NOT AND HOW WE CAN IMPROVE IT
AND I THINK THIS BILL- IS VERY
CONSISTENT WITH THAT PHILOSOPHY
THAT I. I THINK IT'S A
NECESSARY ONE AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR LEGISLATION TODAY
DID YOU HAVE A FOLLOW. UP ON
AGAIN THE CONCERN YOU KNOW SO
WHAT A MAJOR DONOR TYPICALLY-
YOU KNOW THAT'S MONEY THAT GOES
FOR INSTANCE TO ME- THEN
THERE'S A TO REPORTING
FRAMEWORK BUT THERE IS NO SUCH
WORK FRAMEWORK FOR SOMEBODY
JUST DECIDES BE SPECIALLY
VARIANT THE ONLINE TOOL TO DONE
TO TAKE OUT ADS. ON FACEBOOK ON
ON YOUTUBE OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT SO YOU COULD EASILY GET
VERY FAR ALONG IN SPENDING THE
AGGREGATE OVER FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. WITHOUT ANY CONTACT AT
ALL WITHOUT WITH THE F. B. PC
AND NO BASIS FOR EDUCATION SO
YEAH GOD DID SPEAK TO YOUR
POINT TO WORK IN PROGRESS WHICH
IS SOMETHING I HINK WE SHOULD
THINK ABOUT. GREAT IT'S A GREAT
POINT SENATOR HAVING COME UP
BEFORE BUT BUT IT'S VERY WELL
TAKEN AND- LET'S LET'S HAVE A
CHAT YOUR ME MAYOR STUFF AS
WELL AND COMMITTEE STAFF THAT.
THIS FIGURE OUT A WAY TO ENSURE
THAT THIS IS UNFAIRLY. THANK
YEAH RIGHT SAN I WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE YEAH I WITH FIGURE A
DISCUSSION I JUST I WANT TO SEE
WITH WITH WITH- WITH SO MUCH
RESPECT AND TO MY AND THE VICE
CHAIR I JUST TO CLARIFY I
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
MY AND- BUT- THAT. BIT YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS NOT.
THIS IS NOT. I'M CREATING ANY
NEW WOULD DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS THE IT JUST
BASICALLY MAKES IT IT MAKES IT
MAKES DIFFERENT THE DISCLOSURE
COME SOONER RIGHT SO UNDER
CURRENT LAW. EVERYBODY STILL
EVERYBODY'S GOING TO HAVE TO
DISCLOSE INTO THIS AT LEAST
WITH REGARDS TO THE LOBBYING
ACTIVITY IF THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
FOCUSED ON. OUR WILL STILL HAVE
TO DISCLOSE MAYBE THEY STILL
HAVE TO DISCLOSE WILL ALWAYS
GONNA HAPPEN IN THIS BILL IS
IT'S GOING TO AXE IT'S GOING TO
MAKE IT SO THAT THEY CAN'T JUST
DISCLOSE MONTHS AFTER THE FACT.
SO AND SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE I UNDERSTAND IF YOU STILL
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THAT SORT OF
DISCLOSURE SCHEME IN GENERAL-
IT DOES CREATE NEW
REQUIREMENTS. WITH REGARDS TO
THESE ISSUE ADS AND I THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO BE HONEST I
MEAN I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE
SEEN I MEAN I CERTAINLY
PERSONALLY. I MEAN WE'VE ALL
BEEN TARGETED WITH THESE ISSUE
ADS THAT THEY- ARE SENT
DIRECTLY TO OUR SOCIAL MEDIA
ACCOUNTS AND IN OUR STAFFS AND-
NOBODY ACK HOME SEEMS TO GET
THEM BECAUSE THEY'RE VERY
TARGETED. ARE THERE CLEARLY
BEING. TAKEN OUT TO INFLUENCE
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
EXPLICITLY SO. AND YOU KNOW I
JUST THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE FOR
US AS AS CONSUMERS OF THIS
INFORMATION TO HAVE SOME
INFORMATION AND SOME SOME
DISCLOSURE AS TO WHERE THESE
MESSAGES ARE COMING FROM I'VE
SOMETIMES BECAUSE I'M
INTERESTED IN THIS I SOMETIMES
I'LL GO DOWN INTERNET RABBIT
HOLES TRYING TO DISCOVER WHERE
THE MONEY'S COMING FROM AND
SOMETIMES IT'S NOT VERY EASY-
AND YEAH THIS MONEY IS BEING
SPENT TO INFLUENCE US INFLUENCE
OUR DECISIONS AND IT'S BEING
DONE ACTUALLY YOU KNOW I. LIKE
INDIA AND ADDS TAKEN ON THE
NEWSPAPER. THAT'S AT LEAST ON
DISPLAY FOR THE WHOLE GENERAL
PUBLIC TO SEE THESE ARE ADS
THAT ARE BEING TARGETED CHEST
TO US AND JUST TO OUR STAFFS
THAT ARE NOT AVAILABLE FOR THE
GENERAL PUBLIC TO SEE AND YET
IF THEY'RE THEY'RE BEING THERE
BEING TAKEN OUT TO CREATE THE
IMPRESSION OF A GROUND SWELL OF
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO A
BILL. ON IT YOU AND- AND IT CAN
BE VERY DECEPTIVE AND I JUST
THINK THAT I THINK WE OWE IT TO
OURSELVES AS INDEPENDENT
DECISION MAKERS I WENT ALONG TO
THE GENERAL PUBLIC TO JUST
ENSURE THAT THE RULES THAT WE
PUT IN PLACE CREATE MORE I
TRANSPARENCY SO WE CAN KNOW
WHO'S PAYING FOR THESE THINGS
AND SIMILARLY WITH. REGARDS TO
THE LOBBYING DISCLOSURE.
THERE'S SO MUCH THAT. IN THE
COUPLE OF THE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. AND AT AND
I'VE I'VE PERSONALLY SEEN IT.
AND I JUST THINK WE OWE IT TO
OURSELVES AS WELL. AND THE
PRESS DESERVES TO KNOW AS WELL-
WHERE THIS MONEY IS BEING
SPENT. AT A TIME WHEN IT'S MORE
RELEVANT. WHAT YOU KNOW IT'S
ALL VERY INTERESTING TO GO BACK
AND SEE ALL THAT YOU KNOW THAT
ALL THIS MONEY WAS SPENT.
MONTHS AGO ONCE THE BILLS
ALREADY SIGNED IT'S ALREADY
BEEN VETOED- BUT BUT- BUT BUT
BUT IT'S REALLY ULTIMATELY TOO
LATE IT'S GOT IT'S INTERESTING
FOR HISTORIAN BUT THAT'S ABOUT
IT SO WITH THAT. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL NAY I DON'T THINK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS ENGAGEMENT IN
THIS BILL THANK YOU CENTER
ALLEN IS THERE A MOTION- MOVED.
SENATOR NEWMAN. IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED IS ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS- AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS OF
THE CONSULTING WITH CALL THE
ROLL. SB FORTY FIVE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GLAZER HI GLAZER HI NIELSEN NOT
VOTING. NIELSEN OPERATING
HERTZBERG. LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN FIVE.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL PUT THAT BILL
ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS-
YEAH YEAH OKAY. OKAY YEAH
CENTER ALLEN- WE'RE GONNA PUT
THAT BILL ON CALL IF YOU HAVE
THE OCCASION TO AMEND THIS BILL
FURTHER LOOKING FOR CO AUTHORS
I'D BE HAPPY TO LIKE TO JOIN
AYE BEYOND HAVING CENTER ALL
RIGHT PERSON CENTERED OAKLAND
SO INDICATES AS WELL OKAY WE'RE
GONNA MOVE NOW TO AGENDA ITEM
FOR THIS IS S. B. FIVE NINETY-
AND CENTER ALLEN THIS YOUR BILL
AND YOU'RE WELCOME TO PRESENT
YEAH I. APPRECIATE IT RUNS
UNTIL JUST THIS MORNING WITH
THE THREE BILLS OKAY SO LET ME
START BY ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE NOW
SAYS I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH
THE OFFICE ON THIS BILL AND
THIS IS A MUCH LESS
CONTROVERSIAL BILL PERHAPS- OR
LEASE THAT'S MUCH SIMPLER- HI
THIS BILL EXTENDS THE TERMS OF
MEET LOCAL MUNICIPAL OFFICIALS
THAT ARE SET TO EXPIRE IN THE
MARCH OR APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO- WITH THE POSTPONED TWENTY
TWENTY TWO STATEWIDE PRIMARY.
ELECTIONS SO. I'M IT KNOW BASIC
YOU FOR MAY WERE. BACK TO
FIFTEEN THIS COMMIT. I HEARD IN
L. TO PASS THE- VOTE.
PARTICIPATION ACT WHICH
BASICALLY FORCED THE ALIGNMENT.
OF MANY MUNICIPAL ELECTIONS
WITH A STATEWIDE ELECTION
SCHEDULED TO- IN THE ARGUMENTS
OF THE TIME THIS IS GOING TO BE
OUT INCREASING DOLLARS ACCESS
PROMOTING TURNOUT LOCAL RACES.
REGARDLESS OF WHERE YOU STAND
IN NASHVILLE. AND IT CREATED A
SOME AMBIGUITIES- GIVEN THE
FACT THAT WE THEN TURNED AROUND
AND PASSED THE RECENT BILL I TO
POSTPONE THE STATEWIDE PRIMARY
FROM- FROM MARCH TO JUNE.
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW WE DID THAT
WHEN KOBE CAME IN AND IT THE
LADY AT THE CENSUS DATA
COLLECTION AND- THE MEDICAL OR
SAID AS A RESULT OF DELAYED ARE
REGISTERED IN TWO MISSIONS
ABILITY TO DO ITS WORK. SO A
LOT OF CITIES HI BASICALLY SET
UP THEIR ELECTORAL SYSTEMS
UNDER THE OLD MODEL BUT UNDER
THE NEW UNDER THE NEW MODEL
THAT UNDER THE CALIFORNIA MOTOR
VOTER PARTICIPATION RIGHTS ACT
TWENTY FIFTEEN. ALLY INTO APRIL
AND MARCH THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN
WE KICKED THE PRIMARY INTO JUNE.
AND SO IT'S REALLY CREATED SOME
TROUBLE- AND SO BASICALLY WHAT
WE'RE WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
THIS BILL AS IT PREVENTS.
PROLONGED VACANCIES IT
BASICALLY INSTEAD OF THE LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIAL NOT LIVES
LIVING A VACANCY BETWEEN
BETWEEN MARCH AND JUNE. WE FILL
THE GAP AND WE BASICALLY EXTEND
THE TERMS FOR OFFICIALS THAT
ARE SET TO EXPIRE IN EITHER
MARCH OR APRIL TO ALIGN WITH
THE POSTPONED. TWENTY TWENTY
TWO STATEWIDE PRIMARY ELECTIONS
SO THEN VOTERS WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE FOR THEIR
MUNICIPAL STATEWIDE
REPRESENTATIVE SIMULTANEOUSLY
SO IT'S IT. IT IT JUST IT WILL
IT WILL PROVIDE FOR CONTINUITY
IN A LOT OF OUR LITTLE A LOT OF
OUR CITIES- THAT- THAT YOU KNOW
ADOPTED RULE CHANGES BASED ON
THE TWENTY FIFTEEN LEGISLATION
BUT DIDN'T ANTICIPATE. V. AND-
V. THAT THE POSTPONEMENT OF
TWENTY TWENTY PRIMARY SO WITH
THAT I HAVE- JOE MAYBERRY WHO
CITY CLERK FOR THE CITY OF LAKE
WOULD ALSO AND REENTRY WHO'S
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
BEVERLY HILLS. THANK YOU CENTER
ALICE GO TO YOUR LEAD WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AS THEY- ARE
PROBABLY WARY OF THREE MINUTES
SET ASIDE FOR THEM TO SHARE AS
THEY SEE FIT- MODERATOR HE
WOULD INVITE TO HAVE THIS
MAYBERRY AND- THIS YEAR AND.
WITH TO PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU THE LINES ARE OPEN
YOU MAY BE AT. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JOE MAYBERRY AND I'M THE CITY
CLERK FOR THE CITY OF LIKE
WHAT. WE ARE IMMENSELY GRATEFUL
TO SENATOR ALAN FOR INTRODUCING
THIS MEASURE WHICH WAS ALSO IT
IS REALLY A TECHNICAL ISSUE.
CAUSED BY THE STATE'S DECISION
TO MOVE THE PRIMARY TEACHING
AND GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION
YEARS. AS A RESULT OF THAT
CHANGE BECAUSE WE CONSOLIDATED
WITH THE STATE WE HAVE THREE
COUNCIL MEMBERS WHO WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO SIT ON COUNCIL FOR
THREE MONTHS LEADING UP TO THE
JUNE PRIMARY. THE LOSS OF
REPRESENTATION AND IMPACT FOR
GOVERNANCE EVEN FOR A FEW
MONTHS WOULD BE PROFOUND AND
UNFAIR TO THE CONSTITUENTS
COLLECTED THOSE MEMBERS. WHO SB
FIVE NINETY WE CAN BE CERTAIN
THAT ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS
WILL HAVE FULL REPRESENTATION
LEADING INTO THE JUNE PRIMARY.
THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
THIS MAY BE MISTER AND WITH
PLEASE PLEASE BE A- THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ENTERED
EMPLOYEE HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS I
BELIEVE CENTER ALAN AND- LAID
OUT THE SITUATION VERY CLEARLY-
CITY BEVERLY HILLS FIND THIS
OPEN EXACT SAME. SITUATION AND
THAT WAS LAID OUT BY MS
MAYBERRY SPECIFICALLY THAT
THREE MEMBERS OF THE FIVE
MEMBER CITY COUNCIL PARALEGALS
AND FIND THEMSELVES- WITH NO
ABILITY TO SERVE- WAS THREE
MONTHS LEFT BEFORE THE NEXT
ELECTION DATE OR POSSIBLY
LATER. HELLO WE HEAR YOU NOW
COULD HAPPEN THE STATE'S
PRIMARY INTERNET HAS COURT
CASCADING DOWNSTREAM IMPACTS
THIS WHOLE BILLS CORRECTING IT
DOWNSTREAM IMPACT FROM OUR
COUPLE DEALS PRIOR CURRENT LAW
SPECIALLY PROVISIONS THE
CURRENT LAW THAT DID NOT
PROVIDE A CORRESPONDING
AUTHORITY. FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO EXPAND THE
TERMS TO MATCH THE DATE- OF THE
NEW PRIMARY WHICH AGAIN MIGHT
BE EVEN LATER SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS FOR AWHILE WE TRIED
MITCHELL YOU TO ADDRESS IT BUT
GET IT ADDRESSED IN THE RECENT
LEGISLATION OF LAST YEAR SB
FIVE NINETY BUT WE'RE-
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL- THE CENTER
ELEMENT TO THIS COMMITTEE- TO
TAKE THIS MATTER UP AND APPROVE
IT. AND WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES HERE
IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE I WANT
TO PUT THEIR NAME ON THE RECORD
IN SUPPORT OF- SB FIVE NINETY.
YOU KNOW HANDS UP I'LL GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. YOU KNOW HANDS
UP THERE WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MODERATOR
WOULD YOU INVITE ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF SB FIVE NINETY TO PLEASE SO
INDICATE. THANK YOU TO STATE
SUPPORT THREE FOR NINETY OR
PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR TOTAL
KEYPAD. I CAN. ONE BY PLEASE.
WE DO HAVE ONE LINE IN Q. BE
JUST A MOMENT. AS A SECOND
REQUESTED ANYONE WANTS TO SPEAK
TO SUPPORT FOR SB. FIVE HUNDRED
ALLOTMENT SB FIVE FIVE NINE
ZERO THANK YOU. SB FIVE NINETY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE TECHNICAL
COLD DELAY WE DO HELP ONLINE IN
CUBA JUST A MOMENT.
ONE TWENTY
EIGHT TO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS B. J. AND MARY
ARE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND WITH THE DEEP
GRATITUDE TO SENATOR HOLLAND
FOR INTRODUCING THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU KNOW
FOR THE LINES IN SUPPORT AT
THIS TIME OKAY I DON'T HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION LISTED SO WE'LL
GO TO ROADS THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION HERE IN THIS ROOM.
SINGLE HANDS UP WILL GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE. THE NEW HAMPSHIRE
THERE WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. OPERATOR
WOULD YOU ASK ANYONE WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
SP FIVE NINETY TO PLEASE SO
INDICATE. THANK YOU I WAS
DATING A PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD TO STATE
YOUR POSITION OF OPPOSITION TO
S. B. FIVE NINETY ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO PLEASE. POSTED A SECOND
REQUEST IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE
YOUR POSITION OF OPPOSITION TO
SB FIVE NINETY ME PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE MAY
HAVE ONE NINE IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
APOLOGIZE FOR THE
CONFUSION MR I BELIEVE THERE
ARE NO LINES IN Q. U. MAKING
THANK YOU THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM ANYONE SEEN
NINE. CENTER ALLEY LIKE TO
CLOSE. YOUR DRIVER ON THIS.
THANK YOU FOR CITIES THANK YOU
CENTER ON THE THINK THE- WHAT
TO SEE THIS. CORRECTION BE DONE
IN A LEGISLATION SUCH AS YOURS
AND HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT. OUR
MOTION FOR THE COMMITTEE.
CENTER LEVELS MOVE THE BILL- AS
AMENDED IS THAT CORRECT
CONSULTANT. YES YES AS AMENDED
SO PLEASE COLOR. SB FIVE NINETY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE
NIELSEN. WILSON I HERTZBERG.
LEYVA FLAVOR HI NEWMAN HI
NEWMAN FIVE. PRICE AT AROUND
THAT BILL IS FOR THOSE WILL
HOLD THE ROLL UP AND WRAPS IN
NUMBERS MAKING MEMBERS REVEALS
TODAY THREE BILLS OUT THERE
SECRETARY SANDY KOUFAX. SENATE
OKAY THREE STRIKES ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON OUR AGENDA
TO- THE NEXT ITEM IT SENATOR
CAFIERO IS SHE THE NOTIFIED
THAT WE'RE READY. TO OKAY. I'VE
CENTER HERTZBERG SEND THAT IN
THE BUILDING AND BE THROUGH
HERE WILL TAKE UP HIS BILL.
RIGHT WHEN WE TAKE A SHORT
RECESS SENATOR CAFIERO AND SEND
HER THROUGH PLEASE COME TO ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE SO WE CAN
HEAR YOUR BILLS. TAKE A SHORT
RECESS.
AND A COMMITTEE
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
MEMBERS BACK TO ORDER WE DO
HAVE AN AUTHOR HERE IN THE ROOM-
INVITA CENTER HERTZBERG TWO
PERCENT- I TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX US BEFORE FOR THREE SENATOR
HERTZBERG WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU WE CAN
PROCEED IF YOU SEE FIT. FOUR
FOUR SEVEN AGO THIS OF THE
REFERENDUM. WITH YES YEAH OKAY
THIS IS THIS IS A SENATOR-
NEWMAN'S BILL HE WAS SO
GRACIOUSLY TO. THEY GIVE IT TO
ME. BUT THIS. SO THIS IS A
HISTORIAN I AM VERY BRIEFLY.
YOU KNOW WE DEVELOPED IN
CALIFORNIA THE DECK A CENTURY
AGO. REFORM MOVEMENT THAT CAME
FROM A VERY CORRUPT SYSTEM
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE WAS
DRAMATICALLY IMPACTED BY THE
RAILROADS THE REFERENDUM TO
RECALL THE INITIATIVE WE SAID
THAT LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS
WERE NOT GOOD BUT WE'RE GOING
TO BE NONPARTISAN. AND WE HAVE
TRIED OVER THE YEARS TO.
MODERNIZE THESE VARIOUS-
SYSTEMS THAT ARE INFORMED BY
THE POWER OF THE ELECTORATE ON
THE ONE HAND BUT THAT HAVE BEEN
ABUSED TO SOME EXTENT BY. SOUTH
SIDE INTERESTS AND ONE THAT'S
PARTICULARLY TROUBLESOME OF
LATE IS THE REFERENDUM.
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
COME TOGETHER AND PASS A LAW
BUT THE PEOPLE HAVE IT RESERVES
THE RIGHT TO OVERTURN THAT LAW.
AND TAKE IT FOR A FULL VOTE.
WELL THE WAY THE LAW IS WRITTEN
CREATES A- UNFAIR DISADVANTAGE
THE PARTIES THERE'S TWO
ELEMENTS TO IT ONE IS IT SAYS
THAT IF IT'S A REFERENDUM IS A
LAST ON THE BALLOT. THIS LAST
YEAR THERE WAS A DROP OFF
BETWEEN THE TOP OF THE BALLOT
IN THE BOTTOM OF THE BALLOT BUT
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION PEOPLE.
SECOND IT'S WILDLY CONFUSING
BECAUSE GENERALLY A PROPONENT
OF A MEASURE ONCE A YES. AND
THE OPPONENT WANTS TO KNOW WHAT
IN THE ISSUE OF A REFERENDUM
IT'S EXACTLY OPPOSITE. THE
PROPONENTS ONE I YES I MEAN THE
OPPONENTS WANNA YES BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO MAINTAIN THE LAW.
AND SO WE HAVE S. C. A. ONE
WHICH WILL COME BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE AFTER THE INITIAL
DEADLINES. AND THIS IS A
COMPANION MEASURE THAT WAS
BEING CARRIED. BY THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA AND NOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL BONTA. AND
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T GO FOR YOU
KNOW I WAS HE'S NOW IN A
DIFFERENT JOB WE BROUGHT THAT
BILL BACK TO THIS HOUSE IT WAS
PART OF THAT PACKAGE I WAS KERN
CONSTITUTIONAL MOMENT HE WAS
CARRYING THE STATUTORY FEES.
AND CENTER NEWMAN HAS BEEN
GRACIOUS ENOUGH TO ALLOW US TO
GIVE US HIS BILL. WHICH EVEN
GOTTEN AMENDED TO BE ABLE TO
PUT THOSE PROVISIONS SO. IT
REALLY IS A WAY THAT IT AND THE
SOLUTION IS NUMBER ONE THAT
MEASURE BECAUSE THE WAY THE WAY
THE COULD THE LAW CONSTITUTIONS
WRITTEN IS THERE ORDERED YOU
KNOW FIRST HIS INITIAL BONDS.
THEN INITIATIVES BY THE
LEGISLATURE PUT OFF THE OTHERS
BUT PUT ON THE BALLOT AGAIN THE
LAST IS. IS THE REFERENDUM THIS
SAYS THAT REFERENDUMS ARE PUT
ON THE BALLOT IN ORDER THAT
THEY QUALIFY AND THEY'LL
USUALLY NOW BE AT THE TOP
BECAUSE- IF YOU'RE OVERTURNING
IT THE LAW REQUIRES A REALLY
QUICK. TURNAROUND IN TERMS OF
GETTING YOUR SIGNATURES IN THE
SECOND IT CLARIFIES THE YES
VERSES YESTERDAY NO OVERSEAS
NOW. I'LL TAKE THE AMENDMENTS
TO THE COMMITTEE BECAUSE THAT
THAT WAS PRETTY SMART WHAT YOU
GUYS DID MADE CLEAR IT EASIER I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND SO IT'S
REALLY A BIG ISSUE IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW WE SEE THIS NOW WITH
PLASTICS SINGLE TOBACCO WE SING
OVER AND OVER AGAIN. WHERE THE
ABILITY OF INTEREST GROUPS TO
OVERTURN THE POWER OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE POWER OF THE
GOVERNOR. AND WITH RESPECT TO
THE BILL THAT I WAS INTERESTED
IN THE POWER OF THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH WITH THAT. I WOULD ASK
YOU AND I BOTH AND I DON'T
THINK I HAVE A W. WITNESSES YES
YES I DID OKAY CENTER THANK.
TAKE FROM THERE. OKAY YOU HAVE
A LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF
CENTER HERTZBERG'S MEASURED
ROSE FROM THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS- PERFECT OPERATOR IF YOU
DON'T HAVE HER PHONE LINE. AND
WE CAN- TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
THE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS RATHER AGAIN DIRECTOR
WITH THE LEGAL IS A CALIFORNIA
HOPE AND WEAR EARS OUT HERE-
THE ONLY SUPPORT OF THE- OF SB
FOUR FOUR THAT KEEP. STATUTORY
LAW IN THE OF A FEW. WE BELIEVE
THAT A REALLY GREAT. YOUR
STATEMENT. YES VOTE FAVOR OF
THE REST TO. LEGISLATION AND
VOTE AGAINST THE REFEREE TO
OVER THE STATE. BUT GOAL REALLY
WAY TOWARD AMELIORATE VOTER.
THE ONLY WORKS TO EDUCATE AND
EMPOWER VOTERS TO WHAT WOULD
CONFIDENCE AND IN THE IS ABOUT.
I'M SURE THE VOTING FOR IS AND
THEN. PLAY LANGUAGE IS A VERY
PART OF THE TO ENTER. THANK YOU
THAT ENDS FOR WE PUBLISH IT IF
YOU VOTER GUIDE EVERY CYCLE AND
WE VERY CLEAR ON BY SUMMER
ABOUT MEASURES THAT ARE
COMMUNITY REVIEW BY PEOPLE OF
THAT ARE TO MAKE THAT. FOR
REFERENCE. WE HAVE TO ENSURE TO
CARLO BOX. THAT HE OR DOES NEED
WHAT IT DOESN'T PROPOSITION.
THE PROBLEM IS AND CENTER
HERTZBERG INDICATED THE CURRENT
FRAMING IS REALLY COUNTER. TO
VOTERS OF THE LOT OF CONFUSION.
AFTER WHETHER THEIR BODIES
OVERTURN OR TO PRESERVE A LOT
WE GET A LOT OF QUESTIONS TO
WHY IN. WHICH THE PRIVILEGE.
AND THEN YES HONORING DIVIDE
OVER THAT. THE VOTER NATURAL
FUNCTIONS. IS THAT THERE YES
SAYS IT'S GOING TO FOR CAMPAIGN
OVER THE LAW. AFTER ALL YOU
KNOW I WOULD PREFER OF ON THE
ONE YOU TO VOTE. UNDER THE
CURRENT JUST WE GO TO IF.
LENGTHS TO INTEREST THE CAN. OF
REFERENDUM ON. AND AFTER ONE
WITH OUR JOB AND YOU VOTERS ON
LOT OF YOU. NOW THE LANGUAGE
MEANING OF THE VOTE NO VOTE THE
BALLOT IS A VERY. COMPLEMENT OF
THE CHAIN. SO WE'RE VERY MUCH
IS OF COMMITTEES. TO WORK WITH
THIS OF STATE'S BALLOT DESIGN.
THE IS. A GETTING UP AND
RUNNING. HELLO TO ENSURE THAT
THE BALLOT QUESTION AND THE
VOTING OPTIONS REALLY REALLY
COPPER ALL. BELIEVE SUPPORT AS
SHE ONE AND THE INFIRMFROM OF
FOUR FOUR. I THINK DESIGNED TO
HELP VOTERS UNDER THEIR- IN THE
CAN FOR DECISION AND WE- BEEN
NOR. APPRECIATE CENTER
HERTZBERG WORK ON THIS LEADER.
AND WE ARE JOB. THANK THE ROSE
FOR YOUR TEST WE'VE HEARD FOR
THE LEGAL SINCE OF THE BILL.
WILL GO TO OTHERS WITHOUT IT
LIKE TO PUT THAT IN. ON THE
RECORD IT'S A AS WELL. VERSED
IN ROOM ONE ONE HANDS UP HERE.
SENILE GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SEEING NO HANDS UP THERE WILL
GO O THE TELECONFERENCE LINE.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU A QUEUE UP
ANY INDIVIDUAL WANTS TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR FOUR
THREE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
PLEASE. THANK YOU STATE YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR FOUR THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO THE
STATE YOUR POSITION OF SUPPORT.
NO ONE IN Q. INITIALLY I WILL
REPEAT THE STATE SUPPORT FOR S.
B. FOUR FOUR THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU THERE ARE NO LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL NOW GO
TO- WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION I
DON'T HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
NOTED. THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE SO INDICATE. C. NO HANDS
OUT OF THE ROOM ONE TWELVE. YOU
KNOW HANDS UP THERE WILL GO TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU ASK ASK
ANYONE WHO IS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR FOUR
THREE TO SO INDICATE. THANK YOU
TO STAY IN A POSITION OF
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR FOUR
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AGAIN THAT'S A ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO PROPOSITION. WE DO HAVE A
LINE OR TWO IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WELL THE FIRST LINE
TWENTY SEVEN TWO SEVEN THE LINE
IS OPEN. SH HI CHRIS LANG CAL
PRICKLY MONDAY CAMPAIGN DON'T
MEAN TO SCARE YOU ARE WE ARE
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT I JUST
COULDN'T GET ON TO SUPPORT
WIDENING TIME. THANK YOU YOUR
DRIVE UP. THANK YOU MISTER LACK
I HOPE THAT YOUR FINGERS DO THE
WALKING A LITTLE FASTER NEXT
TIME. ADULT GRACIOUSNESS AND
HUMOR OKAY OPERATOR ANYONE ELSE
INCLUDED TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SB FOUR FOUR THREE
BUT- NO ONE ELSE COMPUTER AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD
WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. A SENATOR NEWMAN
I'M SORRY FOR AND I LIKE I LIKE
WHAT YOU'VE DONE WITH MY
VEHICLE. REALLY APPRECIATE THE
MODIFICATION. HAVING SAID THAT
DID GLANCE FOR THIS BILL- AND
WOULD LOVE BE AS CO AUTHORS IF
THE IF AND WANTED TO MANAGEMENT
FOR THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN.
CENTER HERTZBERG I WOULD ALSO
ADD MY APPRECIATION FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN A PARTICULAR WHO
WERE PART OF OUR A LOT. THAT
THE QUESTIONS ABOUT QUESTIONS
BEEN WORDED THIS WAY I THINK
THIS IS A- A VAST IMPROVEMENT.
FOR CLARITY FOR OUR VOTERS AND
THANK YOU FOR BRING IT FORWARD
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE WOULD YU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THE SESSION.
OKAY IS THERE A MOTION. THAT IS
ACCEPTED. THE AMOUNTS WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THIS BILL. SAN EVEN.
MOVE OKAY CENTER AHEAD NEW HAS
MOVED THE BILL AS AMENDED IF
THE CONSULT WILL CALL THE ROLL.
SB FOUR FOUR THREE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN- HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
AYE LEYVA. LIVER FIVE NEWMAN.
NEWMAN FIVE. SO WE HAVE A FULL
COMMITTEE SAT RIGHT ON THAT SO
THAT BILL IS OUT OF FOUR TO ONE
GRADUATION CENTER HERTZBERG
OKAY WE HAVE ONE BILL
REMAINING- AND THAT'S- SB SEVEN
FOURTEEN BY CENTER COPIER OF
HIS PRESENTING ANOTHER
COMMITTEE WE WELCOME HER HERE'S
AND SHE'S ABLE TO SEE WALL-
WE'RE WAITING LET'S GO BACK TO
THE ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO-
TO VOTE THEY WOULD LIKE-
CONTROL WHEN YOU GO BACK TO THE
TOP THIRTY WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THANK YOU CHAIR ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE MOTION
IS T ADOPT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WHICH INCLUDES SB
SEVEN TO NINE SB SEVEN NINE
FOUR. THE CHURCH BUILDING OUR
INVESTOR VOTING AYE HERTZBERG
AYE HERTZBERG AYE. AND THEN
VOTE TALLIES THAT EVERYONE
VOTING THAT IS YES I DON'T THAT
THOSE BILLS ARE UP BY TWO ZERO.
ON TO THE NEXT. ONE FIFTY SEVEN
FIVE TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
CURRENT VOTE IS. AT THREE ONE
WITH TERRORISM I AM VERY SURE
VOTING NO HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG
AYE. AYE THAT BILL IS OUT FOUR
TO ONE. THANKS ITEM NINE THREE
SB FOUR FIFTY NINE ALLEN. IS
BEFORE FIFTY NINE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
VOTE IS THREE ZERO- WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING AYE. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG I. ZERO FIVE. NEITHER
NIELSEN THE OKAY THAT BILL IS
FOR THE- ITEM NUMBER FOUR FIVE
NINETY. HI YES SB FIVE NINETY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE VOTERS FOUR ZERO
WITH THE TURN BY SURE VOTING
AYE. HERTZBERG MISTER GUY. AND
A VOTE THE TOTAL ON THAT FIVE
ZERO I THAT DILUTES OUT FIVE
ZERO. FAR THAT CATCHES UP WHILE
WE WAIT FOR CENTER COPIER WILL
WILL GO INTO A SHORT RECESS.
THANK.
SB SEVEN FOURTEEN BY
SENATOR COPYWRITER STAND SHE'S
GIVEN PERMISSION TO CENTER
HERTZBERG PRESENTED ON HER
BEHALF- AND PERCENT HERTZBERG
SOMEWHERE IN AS WE DO HAVE TO
LEAD SUPPORT- WITNESSES THAT
CAN GOOD VERY GOOD ALSO I WANT
TO INVITE YOU TO PRESENT SB
SEVEN FORTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN I JUST WANT TO
FOR THE RECORD. CONFIRM THAT- I
SPOKE TO- OUR- WOOD PULLUM
TERMS IT WOULD SPECIAL BERNICE
TITLE DEPUTY SECRETARY OF THE
SENATE SB NANTI AND- ITALY'S
PERMISSION I WENT JUST SPOKE TO
THE AUTHOR AND SHE OVERLY GAVE
ME PERMISSION THIS IS SENATE
BILL SEVEN ONE FOR THE
PREFERRED AREA CODE. BOND AND
BASICALLY WHAT THE BILL DOES
CURRENTLY. CURRENT LAW ONLY
PERMITS A PERSON TO BE ELIGIBLE
IF THEY ARE REGISTERED AS
AFFILIATED WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THE EX THIS EXCLUDES NON
CITIZENS YOU CANNOT REGISTER AS
DEMOCRATS BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
ELIGIBLE TO REGISTER TO VOTE.
BUT IT'S JUST SUPPORT OF A
WHOLE HOST OF INDIVIDUALS SOME
OF WHOM TESTIFIED. AND SO IT IT
THE MEN'S ELECTIONS CODE
SEVENTY TWO OH NINE. IN EXPANDS
IT IN THAT MANNER WITH THAT
RESTAURANT I VOTE IN LAST
GERMAN TO CALL ON THE-
WITNESSES GREAT THANK YOU
CENTER HERTZBERG AND AS I
UNDERSTAND IT- THE THING CARE
IS ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT CORRECT OKAY. SO
LET'S INVITE TO WE AVE- ONLINE
SERVICES- AND CARLOS ALL
CALLERS. TO TESTIFY AS LEGAL
DECISION SUPPORT MODERATOR
WOULD YOU INVITE THEM BOTH TO A
TO A- SHARE THEIR THOUGHTS WITH
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU TOTAL
UNDER OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING
THIS IS SERAPHIM. SHOULD I GO
NOW YES PLEASE ZERO INTRODUCE
YOURSELF YOUR WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO CONDITIONS FOR ALL IS
THAT CORRECT AND PLEASE GO
AHEAD GO AHEAD. YES OKAY. HI
GOOD MORNING- I'M TERRIBLE NEWS
THAT ARE. A. M. A DREAMER DAHLE
AGAIN AND ALSO THE CULTURE- AT
THAT COMMISSION FOR ALL- GOOD
MORNING- HONORABLE CHAIR BLAZER
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY-
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR-
SB SEVEN FOURTEEN WHICH WOULD
ALLOW I THANK GOODNESS I MIGHT
TELL YOU. GET ELECTED FOR OUR
HONEY CENTER COMMUNITY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA I HAVE BEEN LEAVING
SAN FRANCISCO FOR TWENTY YEARS.
AND FEEL VERY PROUD OF BEING A
CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE TODAY
TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
ATHLETES AT ONE FOURTEEN. WHICH
WOULD ALLOW ME AND TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION FROM OCCURRING IT
IS YOU SHOULD HAVE A SEAT AT
THE TABLE. WE CONTRIBUTE
MILLIONS OF NEW TAXES AND BRING
OUR UNIQUE CULTURE TO OUR
GOLDEN STATE. 39% MCCARTY
AMENDED ITS BYLAWS WILL ME A
THE FIRST REMARKS I THIRDS- OF
THE PEOPLE. I A PROP HEALTH I
HAVE BEEN PHYSICALLY ARE WE AND
THAT AND HAVE HAD ACTED FOR TO
BE WITH PARTY LAST YEAR I WAS
OF. AS THE STATE FOR KATE.
AFTER IT'S AMENDMENT. AND NOW I
HERE TO ASK YOU COMPLETE SB
SEVEN. CHIU FROM A MORE
INCLUDES TOMORROW FOR ALL.
SENATOR PROBABLY IT'LL- IS
LEADING THIS APP. CHIU REALLY
THAT AGAIN ALL- CAL. HOW THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROBE THEIR- AND
FORGIVE IN ARE GOOD. IF YOU
KNOW GROW TO A POLICE THE BOY
FROM KIND. DREAMERS AND ALL
THERE'S CITIZENS MUST HAVE A TO
AT THE TWO AGAIN. I WANT TO
THINK ALL OF. THE- OPERATIONAL.
BITDEFENDER MAKE AND AGAIN HAVE
NOT YET HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REPRESENT THEMSELVES I MISS.
ROGERS NEIGHBORHOOD I WANT TO
MAKE SURE YOU HAVE THE FAMILY
FEW MINUTES LATE I MEAN IT LEFT
FOR YOUR OTHER OTHER WITNESS TO
TEST SO IT ASK IF YOU CAN WRAP
UP AND WILL LET OKAY HARLESS.
BECAUSE YEAH I WILL WRAP UP. IN
TO RIGHT NOT GOING OUT I URGE
YOU AGAIN TO COMPETE- YOU WHAT
I'M LIKE GOAL AGAIN TO ALLOW
OUR TELL WITH ARE IN. WHAT YOU
NEED SPEAK. TO- ON THE PART OF
SB SEVEN FOUR AND I WOULD.
REQUEST ABLE THANK VERY MUCH IS
A THIS OP MISTER CALL WE HAVE
TO. LATER LEYVA TALK TO HER IN
A LONG TIME BUT THIS WILL ALLOW
DEMOCRATIC PARTY PRIVATE
ELECTIONS. TO- HAVE. REEMERGE
IN OUR PARTY WE'VE BEEN DOING
IT FOR A LONG TIME IN THE
CHICANO LATINO CAUCUS WE'RE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY. IT'S WORKED
PERFECTLY FOR US I'M SURE IT'LL
WORK PERFECTLY ON A BROADER
SCALE WITH WITH SKILL WITH THE
CENTRAL COMMITTEE. I'M A MEMBER
OF THE CENTRAL COMMITTEE MY
WIFE IS THE VICE CHAIR OF THE
YOLO COUNTY CENTRAL COMMITTEE
AND WE URGE YOU TO ALLOW OUR
PARTY- TO DO WHAT IT CARE. TO
GROW AND TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO
JOIN OUR PARTY IF THEY WANT TO
GET BETTER QUICK CITIZENSHIP
VERY GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND FOR YOUR PATIENCE
BOTH OF YOU. AS WE- WAITED TO
HEAR THIS BILL ALL RIGHT WE'VE
HEARD FROM THE LEAD- SUPPORT
WITNESSES WE'RE GONNA GO TO A
GROUP OF. THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
FOR ANYONE ELSE. TO ADD I. ON
THE RECORD THAT SEEN NO HAN UP
A VOTER ONE TWO. YOU KNOW OF
THEIR LOGO THE TELE. LINE MY
WOULD YOU ASK. DOES ANYBODY
WOULD LIKE TO PUT THEIR NAME ON
THE RECORD IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN FOURTEEN BY SENATOR
CABALLERO TO SO. INDICATE THANK
YOU LIKE TO STATE YOUR POSITION
OF SUPPORT TO SB SEVEN ONE FOUR
SEVEN FOURTEEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO STATE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN
FOURTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THANK YOU
KERN ALIGNED IN CUBA TO SAY
THANK YOU MODERATOR SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO THE TO
OPPOSITION NOW. NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES NOTED ALL
THAT GO TO ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE HERE IN OUR HEARING
ROOM FOR ANY HANDS UP SIGNAL GO
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. THE NO
HANDS UP THERE WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINES OPERATOR
WOULD YOU ASK DOES ANYONE WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN FOURTEEN TO PLEASE
INDICATE. THANK YOU THE STATE A
POSITION OF OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN FOURTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. THAT'S
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN FOURTEEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. NO ONLINE TO NATIONALLY
ALL ASK A SECOND TIME THE STATE
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN FOURTEEN
PLEASE PRESS LONDON ZERO AT
THIS TIME. COLONEL NINETEEN Q.
YOU MAY CONTINUE THANK YOU
MODERATOR THANKS FOR ALL YOUR
GOOD WORK TODAY APPRECIATED
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SANDERS ANYBODY HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER LEYVA. FIRST OF THE BILL
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE BUT I
JUST WANT TO SAY HOW MUCH I
LOVE THIS BILL I'VE WORKED WITH
SO MANY DREAMERS OVER THE YEARS
WHO ARE JUST BRILLIANT ADULTS.
AND THEY BRING SO MUCH TO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY LIVE IN
AND BRINGS WOULD BRING SOME
MUCH TO THE PARTIES- SPECIALLY
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY SO I LOVE
THIS BILL THANK YOU SENATOR
CABALLERO AND AGAIN WITH IT
WHEN THE APPROPRIATE TIME
COMES. I THINK THAT TIME MAY
COME CENTER HERTZBERG WE WANT
TO CLOSE YEAH I DO I DO BECAUSE
I WANT TO ADD A COUPLE OF
THOUGHTS TO. SET A CAREER
WANTED ME TO SHARE AND THAT IS.
AND IT RELATES THE POWER BECAME.
OFTEN AS CHAMPION IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS LEGISLATION. AND
INITIATIVES BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT IMMIGRANTS ARE
PART OF THE VERY FABRIC. THAT
MAKES CALIFORNIA ONE A LEADING
WORLD ECONOMIES. WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT DIVERSITY MAKES
A BETTER SOCIETY. AND THAT THIS
MEASURE SB SEVEN FOURTEEN
REMOVES A SYSTEMIC BEAR THE
KEEPS IMMIGRANT LEADERS.
VISITED THE TABLE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ASTRONOMICAL.
TRIFECTA RECOGNIZED COMPULSIONS
CENTER LEYVA THIS IS THE PATH
AS AMENDED AS A CONSULTANT TO
CALL THE ROLL. SB SEVEN ONE FOR
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED GLAZER AYE GLAZER AYE
NIELSEN. HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG AYE LEYVA LEYVA HI
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN HI THE
BILL IS OUT FOUR ZERO- WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
INVOLVEMENT IN PATIENTS TODAY
IN OUR TESTIMONY IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY- YOU COULD
STILL SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS
PRESSURES ON THEM IT'S OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE. COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS REPORT TO US ONE
FINAL INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE THANK YOU MEMBERS
THANK YOU TO OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR GOOD WORK AND
WITH THAT OUR AGENDAS INCLUDED
THIS SENATE COMMITTEE ELECTIONS
A CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT. IS
IT YOUR.